Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Was mir schon die ganze Zeit umtreibt, dieser Coup, bist du das eigentlich?
Ich weiß nicht, äh wer cool ist, es scheint aber auf jeden Fall sehr kluge Figur zu sein. Ich meine, es gibt auf jeden Fall kluge Leute auf beiden Seiten, ja, feine Leute auf beiden Seiten und äh ja, es scheint äh auf jeden Fall kluger kluge Person zu sein. Eine sehr interessante Sachen stehen da im Internet, sehr interessante Sachen. Tim, denk mal drüber nach.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertachtundfünfzig vom vierten September zwanzig zwanzig. Tja, Leute, glaubt nicht, alles, was ihr im Internet lest, glaubt nur, was ihr im Internet hört,
denn das ist die reine Wahrheit und nichts als die Wahrheit. Stimmt's Linus?
Auf jeden Fall. So war, so war mir Kuh helfe.
Vielleicht solltest du auch irgendwie so einen Buchstaben ausgraben. L L Anon.
Nee, hör mal auf mit so Quatsch, dass äh na, am Ende habe ich da irgend so ein Telegram-Kanal und äh.
Na, du hast ja, hast ja gesehen, man muss ja da irgendwie nur äh eine Botschaft reinschmeißen, dass der äh Attila die Raute gemacht hat und dann drehen sie ja schon alle durch. Also,
wenn weißt du, weißt du, wenn der aufgeklärte Widerstand einfach mehr
mehr Mumm hätte und und sich einfach mal ein bisschen frech was trauen würde, dann würden wir die einfach in Grund und Boden trollen. Eigentlich können wir das, aber wir haben diese moralische Hemmung, sowas ja nicht zu machen und deswegen können wir gegen diesen ganzen Unsinn nicht so richtig ankämpfen.
Aber einfach mal so ein paar verwirre äh äh Dinge. Also.
Weißte, was mir ähm was ich so letztens gestern Abend äh so sinnierend bei mir dachte.
Was können wir froh sein, dass wir irgendwann mit dieser Freiheit statt Angstdemo aufgehört haben? Stell dir mal vor.
Du, da liefen schon immer diese Infokrieg äh Vögel mit Rum. So, das hat mich schon von Anfang an gestört.
Gehen. Genau. Und äh da war eine der war ja durchaus ähm.
Neben seriösen Vertretern auch äh weniger seriöse und stell dir mal vor, was dieses Jahr los gewesen wäre, wenn du eine Freiheit statt Angstdemo gemacht hättest. Hallelujah.
Ja, der Name ist durch auf jeden Fall so, also das lässt sich irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig äh äh durchziehen. Ja.
Trotzdem nochmal eine Lanze brechen, also vielleicht sollte man da wirklich nochmal was machen. Du kennst doch bestimmt auch dieses schöne äh Mehm ähm ich weiß gar nicht, wie nennt man denn dieses Mehmen? Wo der Typ sich nach dem Mädel umdreht?
Das Mittel, das mit dem gerade geht, ihn so von der Seite an, du weißt schon.
Ja das das, das, das, das aktuelle äh Leitmehm ist es, glaube ich, ne?
Es hält sich auf jeden Fall super und ähm da kam gerade eine schöne Variante irgendwie und dann erstmal so Most People dreht sich um nach,
enttäuscht blickt.
Zweite Variante, in diesem Fall die Silentists drehen sich um nach enttäuscht sind,
Und dann kommen die äh Verschwörungstheoretiker und die äh schauen sich halt oben nach.
Anstatt die Simple, also es wird zu nehmen. Das traf's irgendwie dann doch ganz.
Ganz gut, so. Deswegen kann man sie eigentlich auch mit noch mehr Schwurbel noch mal extra verschwurbeln. Vielleicht muss man den Schwurbel so lange rumschwurbeln, bis er irgendwie wieder in die richtige Richtung zeigt.
Also du meinst alle in den in diesen Freiheits-Chat rein und sagen, das ist mir hier zu unterkomplex.
Ihr blickt ja überhaupt nicht durch. Das ist alles ganz anders. Ja.
Sie da packen, wo man sie irgendwie am besten kriegen kann. Also hiermit ihr mit euren einfachen Antworten.
Echt, ey. Okay, aber lass uns mal erst mal, bevor wir da.
Ja, also alles viel zu naheliegend ist das doch.
Lass uns mal doch ein bisschen aufs Feedback eingehen, bevor wir gleich hier zu den.
Das machen wir. Ja, Feedback gab's äh zur Corona äh Warn-App. Zum Beispiel berichtet äh Petra,
Von einem Reiserückkehrer Corona äh Test und schreibt ein Bekannter war mit seiner Freundin im Urlaub und das Gebiet wurde in dieser Zeit als Risikogebiet deklariert. Beide haben sich am Flughafen testen lassen. Das Ergebnis kam dann direkt in der CBA,
an. Da stand einfach negativ,
Witzig wurde es als der gleiche Kumpel ein paar Tage später in einem Hotel einchecken wollte, in einem Fragebogen musste angegeben werden, ob er die letzten vierzehn Tage in einem Risikogebiet war, um keine Falschaussage zu machen, hat er ja angekreuzt. Die Frau hat dann ein negatives Testergebnis verlangt
App hat das aber nicht mehr angezeigt, weshalb er ein Problem hatte.
Die Frau am Schalter wollte ihm dann das Zimmer verweigern. Glücklicherweise hatte ihm seine Freundin aber einen Screenshot ihres negativen Tests aus ihrer App
geschickt gehabt, dann hat er der Frau einfach den Screenshot seiner Freundin gezeigt und gesagt, dass die App das dann doch noch anzeigt und alles war okay. So viel
dazu. Also
Genau, sie meint dann auch noch so, ja, fälschungssichere Anzeige. Das ist im Prinzip dieses Fahrkarten äh Online-Fahrkartenproblem, ne? Also kennt das ja hier in Berlin, wenn man so einen BVG Ticket hat, dann wird der QR-Code ja nicht nur äh angezeigt, sondern irgendwie auch noch mit so einem,
Schwubel.
Bewegungselement äh da drin, nicht dass ich das nie auch äh faken lässt, aber halt nicht so ohne Weiteres mit einem normalen Screenshot. Und ja, dass man sozusagen dann diesen Test nicht,
vorhalten kann, ist klar, aber es hätte ja eigentlich auch noch eine schriftliche, ach nee, man kriegt das wahrscheinlich gar nicht, ne?
Also ehrlich gesagt sehe ich das ein bisschen anders. Ähm also die die eine Sache, die Corona-Warn-App hat eine Reihe an,
User Experience Herausforderung ja? Ich
heute noch Leute auf Twitter, die sich äh beklagen, dass ihnen die Corona-Warn-App einmal die Woche sagt, sie hätten keine Begegnungen gehabt, dabei sind sie sich sicher, dass da Menschen waren, ja? Ähm,
Bei die Corona-Warn-App natürlich nur Risikobegegnungen anzeigt, ja? Also,
Begegnung und Risikobegegnung hier gleich zu setzen ist komisch jetzt kommt diese Meldung allerdings auch nicht von der Corona-Warn-App, sondern von dem Exposé, Exposure, Notification Framework, die hier offenbar exposher,
falls falsch Schere oder Missverständlich übersetzt haben. Die andere Sache ist, wenn du da ein Testergebnis drin empfängst.
Was ich übrigens auch äh kürzlich getan habe. Ähm dann leitet die dich an, das zu löschen für den Fall,
dass du das nächste Mal ähm wieder einen neuen Test machst. Ja, also du kannst immer nur einen Tester drin registrieren und dann holt die sich,
dann nach dessen Ergebnis, ja? Ähm,
Und der dritte Punkt ist, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, da haben wir ja auch schon relativ ausführlich drüber gesprochen, ob wir solche Immunitätsnachweise unbedingt haben wollen, also diese ganze Hotelsituation.
Mir da ohnehin ein bisschen komisch vor, weil ähm also die Corona-App auf jeden Fall nie gedacht war, als äh Nachweis,
gegenüber Dritten, sondern ähm hier eine Notification,
Geschichte ist und ne das Ziel ist ja nicht, dass du beweisen kannst, dass du ein äh negatives Testergebnis hattest, sondern das Ziel ist, dass du über dein Testergebnis zügiger informiert wirst, als wenn dich jemand anrufen würde.
Das riecht.
Und insofern bin ich da, weiß ich nicht, also genau dieses mit dem Screenshot zeigt's ja, also irgendwie, was dat ist mir da alles äh.
Das ist mir da alles komisch, da würde ich eher an an Stelle des Hotels mal überlegen, was denn so eine Policy soll, weil bevor jemand.
Du müsstest ja auch schon von von hoher äh Begabung sein, um einerseits weit gemäß zu sagen, du warst in einem Risikoland, andererseits dann aber den Screenshot für ein negatives Testergebnis zu fälschen, also da sehe ich irgendwie keine,
sehe ich wenig äh Optimierungspotenzial. Was nicht am Ende in Richtung solcher Immunitätsnachweisgeschichten ginge und äh Corona-Hotels und sowas.
Ja. Na trotzdem besteht dieses Problem natürlich, dass man auch Vertrauen schaffen will, indem man auch dokumentieren kann, dass man grade negativ getestet worden ist.
Ja, dann musst du dir ein Corona-Zertifikat kaufen oder so. Also das ist das ist auch ohne die App nicht vorgesehen, ne. Also der, der, der Laborprozess in, im Fall meines Labohres war so, dass die
die veröffentlichen alle vierundzwanzig Stunden irgendwie ein aktualisiertes PDF mit einer Tabelle drin, wo dann drinsteht, positiv negativ.
Mhm. Also wo mehrere Tests drinstehen oder was.
Genau, ja, ja, du kriegst einfach eine, also ja, die machen im Prinzip das, ne, du hast einen Probennummer, die kriegst du mitgeteilt.
Und dann kriegst du eine URL und da wenn du da klickst kommt ein PDF da steht dann immer oben der aktuelle Stand,
Und dann, was weiß ich, dreihundert Seiten oder nicht dreihundert, aber ja doch, könnten paar auf jeden Fall einige Seiten und da stehen dann alle Ergebnisse und jeweils mit Standdoppelpunkt und dann irgendwie,
quasi ID der des Promröhrchens und äh Testergebnis.
Mhm. Also man kriegt nicht individuell eine Nachricht sozusagen. Ist ja auch.
Über die App, ja.
Ach so, aber über dieses PDF wird sozusagen alle.
Der Weg, den dieses Labor hat für Menschen, die keine ähm die keine Corona-Warn-App nutzen. Ähm ist, gehe auf die Webseite, gucke dir PDF an.
F. Hab ich gemacht? Hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert, weil ich ja ein Meck hab. Blöd. Habe ich Apfeleff.
Deswegen funktioniert das nicht oder was? Ach so.
Ja komm, also Labor Laboranbindung, da hatten wir, glaube ich, auch noch Feedback zu.
Genau, Florian schreibt, Feedback zum äh Feedback zum Feedback, Corona-Warn-App und Lambo-Anbindung. Hallo liebes Logbuchteam doch noch mal zu euren Kommentaren, warum dauert eine Anbindung der Laborinformationen, die es an die Corona-Warn-App so lange,
und dann wieder der Hinweis auf Softwareentwicklung et cetera PP und er meint halt,
Leider braucht's halt bei Medizintechnik etwas mehr. IVD, INC, dreiundzwanzig null vier, Verifikation, Validierung, Risikoanalyse, Grobgeschätz kann man kalkulieren, zwanzig Prozent Softwareentwicklung, achtzig Prozent Regulatory,
Overhead, ja, ist nervig, aber.
Günstiges Verhältnis, das ist ein günstiges Verhältnis.
Wahrscheinlich, ja, ist nervig, führt aber dazu, dass medizinische Software ein wenig besser ist, als äh als Gastro-Software, zumindest ein wenig. Ja, das muss ich sagen, ist ein.
Guter Punkt.
Und ähm den haben wir so nicht erwähnt, dass hier natürlich noch eine regulatorische Geschichte ist. Da kenne ich mich auch nicht so aus.
Und äh kann da wenig zu sagen, dass dass das hier noch mit reinkommt, ist klar. Wobei ich mich dann auch frage, ob man nicht auf diesen regulatorischen Overhead äh an der Stelle äh abkürzen könnte.
Äh das halte ich für äh für äh möglich. Ja, dass äh der Prozess bleibt einfach und wir haben ja äh auch
Also ist interessant, wie viel Feedback wir dazu bekommen, weil es ja schon einige Folgen her, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Ähm
Es ist ja nun mal so, dass es bei fünfundsiebzig Prozent der Labore schon mal soweit ist. Bei äh fünfundzwanzig Prozent nicht,
und äh da muss man und da ging es ja insbesondere jetzt in dieser äh Auseinandersetzung zwischen T-Systems und der K.
VBD gibt KBVD oder wie auch immer die digital äh Tochter da hieß von Karsten ärztlichen.
V, B oder so.
BVK so. Das ist auf jeden Fall falsch. Und ähm dann ähm dass sie sich eben regulatorisch zanken,
und und vertraglich zanken und nicht technisch. Ich denke, das ist ja äh das unterstreicht ja auch nur dieser Kommentar von Florian.
So, dann gab's noch zum Roaming.
Genau. Äh Samuel äh fragt zu der EU Lösung, die beschriebene Umsetzung löst also nur das Problem, wenn Infizierte auf Reisen gehen, dass Reisende auf infizierte Einheimische treffen und mit denen die Keys ausgetauscht haben können, bleibt unberücksichtigt. Fragezeichen?
Äh ja, das habe ich unvollständig erläutert. Ähm und will das hier nochmal ergänzen,
also kurz zur Erklärung, diese Idee der internationalen Verteilung, der Schlüssel ist halt die, wenn ich jetzt infiziert bin und ich war im Ausland, dann gebe ich meine Schlüssel auf so einen internationalen Server
ne. Wenn ich aber nicht im Ausland war, aber jemand anderes war, hier in Deutschland,
und äh will an diesen äh Kiran kommen, der da nicht auf dem internationalen Server landet, weil ich war ja nicht im Dings, dann muss er ja sozusagen,
auch bekommen, um gewarnt werden zu können. Das habe ich vergessen zu erwähnen, es ist halt zweigleisig. Also wenn ich,
infiziert bin und im Ausland kommt ihr auf diesen internationalen Server, damit sie sich alle holen können. Wenn äh ich selber jetzt,
Also wenn jetzt eine andere Person nach Deutschland kommt, merkt sich das Telefon, dass äh.
An dem Tag man in Deutschland war. Also es gibt eine explizite Identifikation, in welchem Land, in welchem Zuständigkeits welchem Meldebereich war ich? Und in dem Fall soll tatsächlich eben dieser Kiefer den deutschen Servern geholt werden für diesen Tag.
Und so passt es passen halt dann beide Szenarien äh zusammen.
Also man holt sich immer von dem Land, in dem man war und von allen Reisenden die Kies.
Genau, wenn man, wenn man selber im Ausland war, genau oder.
Genau, von dem Land in dem du warst, Punkt.
Genau und generell halt alles, was so Ausländer noch so sozusagen also Reisende nicht Ausländer.
Genau, die, du, du holst dir von den Ländern, in denen du warst, die Kies und von allen Reisenden in der Erwartung, dass die eventuell eben in,
und damit ist dieses klassische Problem äh
abgedeckt, wo wir sagten, ähm ne, was war das eine Schweizerin trifft auf eine Österreicherin in Frankreich? Ja, Frankreich ist äh das Problem ist, glaube ich, noch nicht gelöst, aber ähm,
dieser Fall wäre eben auch dadurch abgedeckt, weil sich diese beiden Personen jeweils auf den Reiseservern befinden würden und sich außerdem über die Länder, in denen sie waren, informieren würden.
Klappt.
Genau, was da jetzt äh noch drinsteckt und was uns nochmal auf ein weiteres Thema äh führt, nämlich auf ein aktuelles Update, was ganz wichtig ist in dieser Geschichte.
Ist, dass jetzt auf einmal in zunehmendem Maße so Kenntnis über nationale Infrastrukturen Teil dieses ganzen Systems wird.
Bisher steckte diese Information eigentlich nur in Deutschland in dieser Corona-Warnapp. Die hat ihren Server, weiß, wie sie den erreichen kann und schickt da halt äh Kies hin, beziehungsweise holt sich vor allem erstmal dort welche ab.
Und das ist so ein geschlossenes System. Und in dem Moment, wo es international wird,
Sieht man ja schon an dieser Besuchersituation, muss auch hier mal auf jeden Fall eine italienische App auch wissen, wo der deutsche Server ist. Weil irgendwie muss da ja nachgefragt werden können, wenn ein Italiener, der die italienische App benutzt.
Zwei, drei Tage in Deutschland war.
Und ja, jetzt gab es ein Update für diese ganze Exposur Notification von Apple und Google.
Ähm ich vermute mal, dass es jetzt bei Google auch schon released worden ist, habe ich jetzt nicht nochmal gecheckt, beim äh auf iOS ist das jetzt mit diesem dreizehn sieben.
Äh Update mit drin und das bringt jetzt so einen ganz neuen Spin mit ins Spiel,
letztlich ist das die Umsetzung einer frühen Ankündigung, die sie mal gemacht haben, dass sie das Vorhaben es ins System einzubauen, wo immer so ein bisschen unklar war, was damit eigentlich genau gemeint war und das.
Zeichnet sich jetzt ab. Sie nennen das Exposur Notification Express und äh.
Das heißt, im Prinzip die Telefone bringen jetzt diese App Funktionalität der Corona-Warn-App einfach schon mit.
Man braucht jetzt quasi gar keine App mehr. Die App ist mehr oder weniger äh enthalten. Auf Anrit tatsächlich in Form einer automatisch generierten App.
Auf ist das in irgendeiner Form dann in den Settings integriert ins Betriebssystem. Und das heißt.
Es gibt jetzt quasi eine fertige Lösung auf Smartphone-Seite für Länder, die diesen Aufwand eine eigene App zu machen, gar nicht treiben wollen. Die Grundfunktionalität ist ja eh klar,
Und genau die ist jetzt schon Teil des Betriebssystems.
Was natürlich äh ganz nice ist. Das heißt, diese Apps können im Prinzip das, was diese App, was die CWA macht, also.
Kies überprüfen et cetera durchführen und Nachrichten zu stellen et cetera PP und natürlich auch diese Testverifizierung äh machen.
Aber da fehlt natürlich noch eine Komponente, weil dafür braucht's ja auch dann entsprechende Server, wie wir gerade gehört haben, für jedes Land oder für jeden Staat, jeden Zuständigkeitsbereich einer Gesundheitsbehörde.
Muss so eine Infrastruktur existieren und die gibt's auch noch und die hat, wie ich das sehe, Google gehackt,
zumindest veröffentlicht und das sind halt quasi fertige Keyser und fertige Test-Verification Server, also,
wesentlichen eine ähnliche Infrastruktur, wie das jetzt auch für die CWA gebaut wurde, hat Google auch gebaut.
Und diesen Open Saurs liegen rum und jetzt können sich im Prinzip so ein Land.
Ansonsten bisher kein Bock auf den Scheiß hatte, weil alles schwierig, keine Leute, keine Kohle, können sich einfach diesen.
Code nehmen, können den auf irgendeinen Server deployen zum Laufen bringen, konfigurieren und dann läuft das.
Und,
kannst du dem kannst du noch das habe ich wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe du korrigierst nicht wenn's falsch ist. Letztendlich ist deine deine Länderprovision oder deine starken Provisionierung ähm
sogar also du sagst im Prinzip hier, das ist unser Land, das ist unser Server und,
du kannst sogar noch deine individuellen also die die Grenzwerte ab denen du sagst das ist jetzt alles nicht gesehen die kannst du denen auch noch geben.
Genau, das ist ja ein Teil dieser ganzen Geschichte, ne.
Am Ende ein alle, alles worin Corona-Warn-Apps letztendlich variieren können, nämlich die Server, an die sie melden und die Entscheidungsgrenzen.
Ähm wird abstrahiert in eine einheitliche Konfiguration und die kannst du dann eben relativ einfach deployen.
Also, ich habe das.
Also mich haben auch einige Leute angeschrieben, ob das jetzt überraschend ist ähm oder dass das jetzt natürlich hier die die Übernahme der neuen Weltordnung ist,
ich habe den Eindruck gehabt, dass also dass das immer klar war, dass das passieren würde, äh habe ich mir das nur eingebildet. Ich konnte die Quelle auch nicht mehr finden, aber ich war mir eigentlich relativ,
Also es macht nur so Sinn und mir war eigentlich klar, dass Apple und Google das tun würden.
Ja, die Quelle war der UKW-Podcast. Ich habe das mal ausführlich äh hergeleitet. Diese ganze Fragestellung.
Nee, der die Quelle war das Dokument, in dem dieses Framework dargestellt.
Ja da stand nur drin.
Wir werden Funktionalität ins System einbauen, aber es war nicht explizit gesagt, welche Funktionalität genau sie jetzt wie ins System einbauen wollen. Das ist immer offen gewesen. Das ist das war,
Teil der,
ursprünglichen, aller, aller ersten Ankündigungen, als sie das allererste Mal vorgestellt haben, diese Exposur und da haben sie gesagt, wir kommen jetzt demnächst mit so einem so einer AP für Apps und wir bauen dann das auch ins System ein. Aber was das dann genau,
Bedeutet, das war zu dem Zeitpunkt noch äh unklar.
Gut, dann habe ich es einfach äh sinnvoll interpretiert, weil nur das, was sie da machen, ist ja äh sinnvoll.
Also es war ja, es stellt sich ja ohnehin die die Frage, ne, und die die ist ja jetzt eben auch beantwortet. Muss jetzt jedes Land
zwanzig Millionen Euro investieren um letztendlich 'ne auf eine API zu bauen
oder kann man die API dann auch noch eben zu Ende bauen, der Gestalt, dass sie so vereinheitlicht ist,
dass äh dass die Dinge, in denen sich Corona-Apps unterscheiden, das sind nun mal die Freshers und die Notification Server, mehr Varianz, Lässt,
diese Exposur Notification API ja auch nicht zu, ja? Ähm.
Das ist natürlich, also es ist ein sinnvoller und logischer, nächster Schritt, das dann einfach zu vereinheitlichen.
Richtig, ne? Also man ein bisschen Arbeit ist natürlich noch zu leisten, diese Testverification, also man braucht immer noch eine Infrastruktur, äh wie jetzt in Deutschland diese äh Hotline, die Teletans vergibt
beziehungsweise diese Laboranbindungen, die ja noch nicht so zufriedenstellend läuft, wie wir das gerne äh hätten. Das ist etwas, was man dann an diesem Verification Server halt immer noch ranflaschen muss.
Wie das Interface dafür aussieht weiß ich nicht.
Da gibt's, da gibt's 'ne schöne Lösung von T-Systems,
aber ob aber auch das hatten wir hier schon damals gab's noch gar nicht also da war in Deutschland die Diskussion noch gar nicht entschieden,
ob man äh versucht eine äh eigene Lösung zu klöppeln, die keinem internationalen Standard folgt oder ob man,
sich einem dem Standard der beiden Plattformen anschließt, dass natürlich Apple und Google am Ende den das,
den regulatorischen Kram, den komplizierten Teil äh jeweils den den Ländern überlassen.
Richtig. Und und sich jetzt auch gar nicht groß in in den Bereich mit wir betreiben jetzt die Server für Länder äh einlässt, ne? Sondern das müssen die Länder schon immer noch selber machen. Aber man kann, glaube ich, sagen, ich habe mir mal so die Architektur angeschaut,
was sie da wie das so alles interagiert, das ist so im wesentlichen so wie die CBA das macht. Es ist an einer Stelle noch ein bisschen,
einfacher, sie arbeiten da so mit Zertifikaten und ähm ich habe so den Eindruck, dass dass die Arbeit, die da in,
sicherlich auch in der Schweiz et cetera gemacht wurde, also die in Europa gemacht wurde, dieses Projekt schon sehr.
Beeinflusst hat. Also es ist quasi so, es ist ja auch irgendwie eine, wenn man drüber nachdenkt, mehr oder weniger so eine logische Konsequenz, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass man's nicht auch anders äh hätte machen können. Und jetzt manifestiert sich das, ne, also diese gesamte Waren,
Infrastruktur äh besteht im Wesentlichen eben aus diesen drei Komponenten. Das, was auf dem Smartphone läuft und dann eben zwei Server,
die äh im Falle des von Google-Relistens Housecodes vollständig unabhängig voneinander sind und bei der CBA,
haben die noch so ein ganz klein bisschen Interaktion. Ja und muss man mal gucken. Das wird jetzt noch eine Weile dauern. Also aber es ist perspektivisch natürlich so, dass jetzt Länder mit einem,
sehr überschaubaren Aufwand.
Im Prinzip 'ne Infrastruktur bereitstellen können und dann automatisch davon profitieren das auf allen Telefonen das einfach so funktioniert, ohne dass sie irgendwie eine Zeile coacht für die Telefone schreiben müssen.
Ja, wobei ich da auch sagen muss, das war mit der Open Source Zugänglichmachung der Corona-Warn-App ebenfalls der Fall. Ne, also das ist, denke ich, nicht unbedingt der der große,
der große Schritt, wobei es natürlich äh für für ein Land eine einfache Entscheidung ist, zu sagen, alles klar, wir wir machen hier mal, wir setzen mal so einen Docker Container auf und,
und äh äh machen
für Android und iOS und sind quasi fertig. Äh versus äh wir lesen uns in irgendeinen Code ein und versuchen da die die Bilder drin zu ändern. Und die Sprache, das stimmt schon. Ähm ein
relativ entscheidender Aspekt kommt hier noch dazu, Apple. Dadurch, dass es im Betriebssystem ist,
hat Apple und Google natürlich die Möglichkeit, diese Funktionalität auch wieder auszuschalten und zumindest für das dreizehn Punkt sieben Update, was irgendwie gestern oder vorgestern kam für iOS, äh wurde dann gesagt,
Ähm wir behalten uns vor in Region, wo das nicht mehr benötigt wird. Äh diese Funktionalität dann auch ganz einfach wieder zu deaktivieren.
Ja, das wäre also, wenn die USA, die sind ja, wenn das so weitergeht in zwei Monaten zu Ende durchseucht, ähm, dann kann man das da auch schon einfach wieder.
Also das haben sie auch von Anfang an schon gesagt. Das ist jetzt nicht neu mit dem Update, ne?
Okay. Ähm dann würde ich sagen, kommen wir mal zu der zu den Demonstrationsgeschehen in Berlin.
Der letzten Woche.
Der letzten Woche. Also, was war los? Am Samstag, den,
neunundzwanzigsten achten hat eine Demonstration, haben mehrere Demonstrationen stattgefunden, wir hatten auch in der letzten Lokbuchsendung schon von dem Vorgeschehen berichtet, es waren,
ähm es war diese Situation, wo der Berliner Innensenator äh sich bemüht hat, dieses Demonstrationsgeschehen,
zu unterbinden, um diese Versammlung irgendwie zu verbieten, dann irgendwelche Klagen stattgefunden hatten im Eilverfahren und die Versammlung wieder zugelassen wurden.
Es in der Zwischenzeit diese äh Fülle an äh Anmeldungen gab, die quasi,
einfach, dass die Versammlungsbehörde im Prinzip fluten wollten und so. Und jetzt war eben Samstag der große Tag,
an dem sich ähm diese dieses äh diese illustre und bunte Bewegung an verschiedenen Stellen in Berlin versammelt hat. Ähm,
unter anderem an der Siegessäule. Ähm und die erste Versammlung, da bin ich jetzt gerade gar nicht so sicher, wo die war.
Guten Abend Brandenburger Tor, Pariser Platz hinten, die noch rum.
War das dort? Nee, ach so, ja, okay, also ich habe auf auf dem Stream, den ich mir da angeguckt habe, war das äh nicht sofort zu erkennen
und es kam zumindest bei der ersten Versammlung zu äh massenhaften Verstößen gegen die äh Auflagen zum Tragen einer Maske,
bei einer Demonstration, die sich gegen das Tragen einer Maske richtet, natürlich jetzt auch nicht so überraschend ist.
Und ähm dann wurde diese Versammlung aufgelöst, ähm beziehungsweise aufgelöst heißt, die Polizei sagt, das ist jetzt hier beendet. Die Leute sind trotzdem,
stehen geblieben und haben auf den Polizeistaat geschimpft, den sie jetzt durch eine Diktatur beabsichtigen, zu ersetzen. Um
in dieser Diktatur dann mehr Meinungsfreiheit genießen zu können. Ähm dann kam es zu einer äh sehr,
ja, bedauerlichen Situationen.
Vor dem Reichstag, wenn ich das jetzt richtig rekonstruiere, waren zeitgleich diese äh große Versammlung von den Schiefdenkern aus Stuttgart, die übrigens vielen Dank dafür.
Inzwischen angekündigt haben, dass sie den Scheiß demnächst wieder bei sich machen, da finde ich ganz gut. Ähm.
Wobei auch natürlich in den Kommentaren andere Leute schrieben aus der Region, die froh waren, dass sie, dass sie die Spinner zu den anderen Spinnern in Berlin losgeworden sind. Aber okay, ist eine andere Sache. Ähm es war also diese Versammlung an dem,
an äh an der Goldese, also an dem äh an einem großen Kreisverkehr äh ungefähr, wie weit ist der Werk vielleicht anderthalb Kilometer vom,
vom Reichstag. Da war eine große Versammlung. Dann hatte Attila Hildmann mit ein paar ähm,
radikal, Monarchisten, die das Kaiserreich zurückhaben wollen, äh irgendwie vor der, vor der russischen Botschaft äh demonstriert.
Und dort einige Polizeikräfte gebunden.
Und dann gab es noch ein paar, ja ich würde sagen hundert bis dreihundert irgendwo Hansies, die vor dem,
Reichstagsgebäude eine ähm angemeldete Versammlung hatten mit einer Bühne und dann von einer ähm halluzinierenden Heilpraktikerin,
aufgestachelt wurden, die der Überzeugung war, äh Donald Trump sei gerade in Berlin gelandet, um uns alle zu befreien.
Befreit Deutschland, aus den Klammern der Demokratie. So.
Oh Mann ey.
Äh und dieses diese Informationen, die sie jetzt ganz die die Stimmen ihr jetzt gerade gegeben hatten, ja äh.
Veranlasste sie dazu zu proklamieren. Wir haben gewonnen. Und ähm.
Jetzt war es so, dass ähm in den ähm asozialen äh Medien die ganze Zeit schon,
vom Sturm auf Berlin und vom Sturm des Reichtages die Rede war und da ja jetzt quasi ne die Alliiertenmächte schon quasi im Anflug auf Berlin waren, um.
Der Demokratie hier ein Ende zu bereiten, ja? Fühlten die sich dann also ermächtigt, sie müssten.
Den Reichstag stürmen, was dann irgendwie eine Gruppe von ich würde jetzt schätzen, also auf dem Video ich würde jetzt hundert Leute schätzen, waren aber wahrscheinlich.
Also ich würde jetzt mal so sagen, wahrscheinlich nach Angaben der Veranstalter wahrscheinlich irgendwie so zweieinhalb Millionen oder sowas, ne. Und äh die sind dann.
Die Treppe raufgerannt, wo jeden Tag tausende Touristen ihre Selfies schießen und das war jetzt der große Sturm auf den Reichstag. Unglücklicherweise
gab es zu diesem Zeitpunkt wohl, weil die anderen Idioten am, am, am, an der Goldese nicht den Abstand hielten und vor der äh russischen Botschaft irgendwie ähm.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was die da wollten. Vielleicht wollten die auch einfach in die Freiheit klettern, ne? Und ähm da irgendwie bewacht werden mussten, gab es jetzt in einem wahrscheinlich nicht zu verzeihenden äh Fehltritt drei.
Lokale Polizisten vor dem Reichstag, die dann mit ähm Androhung des Knüppelgebrauchs, die dem dem Startstreich,
ein ein schnelles Ende bereitet haben ja die also diese Monarchisten dann vor vor das Parlament,
abhalten konnten. So, jetzt frage ich mich natürlich,
was ist das für eine monarchistische Revolution, wenn du von drei Polizisten zurückgehalten wirst? Ja, obwohl du den quasi die komplette Macht,
äh US-amerikanischen Militärs.
Hinter dir hast, ja? Also die Alliierten im Anflug auf Berlin äh ist jetzt dann leider die monarchistische Revolution an drei Polizisten gescheitert, die gesagt haben, haut ab.
So ist das manchmal mit der Revolution, man macht sich da große Hoffnung und wird dann doch äh von der von der harten Demokratie ähm niedergeknüppelt.
Ich vermute, die hatten einfach keine Fahrkarte gekauft.
Also es ist wirklich äh es es sind natürlich keine schönen Bilder, weil die alle diese schwarz äh weiß-roten Reichsflaggen dabei hatten und wie gesagt ähm.
Wirklich illustre ähm
illustre Halluzinationen haben, ja? Hatten in diesem Zusammenhang. So, jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, was ist das für ein Sturm auf den Reichstag, wenn du grade mal die Treppe hochkommst und dann von drei
drei äh Polizisten ohne Helm und und sonstiges irgendwie zurückgehalten wie es dummerweise passiert jetzt das was,
leider zu erwarten ist, die Medien spielen ganz groß mit. Ganz groß. Das ist in,
im Radio tagelang rauf und runter gelaufen. Es ist im Fernsehen, tagelang rauf und runter gelaufen. Es ist äh von den Parteien
von jedem jeder Ministerin, jedem Minister, jedem Norbert Röttgen hat noch was dazu gesagt, ja, also Leute, von denen du
gar nicht mehr wusstest, dass es die noch gibt.
Jede und jeder musste was dazu sagen und wie dramatisch und wie schlimm und wie scheiße das ist, ja? Was natürlich eine unglaubliche ähm,
Belohnung, an Aufmerksamkeit an diese an diese Menschen ist, die da letztendlich wirklich ja, eine relativ schmale ähm Leistung äh,
haben und an drei Polizisten gescheitert sind, ne? Ähm gleichzeitig muss man natürlich sagen, die haben das sehr klar,
angekündigt. Die Demo hatte Hashtag Sturm auf Berlin äh in allen möglichen Telegrammkanälen wurde spezifisch,
zum Sturm auf das Parlament aufgerufen und da stehen drei, drei Polizisten am Ende, ne? Das äh ist natürlich nicht,
zu entschuldigen, äh dass das so gekommen ist. Jetzt ist es nach meinem Verständnis so, dass es da ein, so ein Unter so ein Zuständigkeiten,
wirr war gibt, dass quasi an dem Reichstagsgebäude ist 'ne andere Polizei zuständig als,
irgendwie vor dem Reichstagsgebäude oder so, wie auch immer es dazu gekommen ist, dass da eine Versammlung von.
Demokratie feindlichen Monarchisten vor dem Parlament stattfindet, die erklärt haben, wir stürmen das Parlament, ja? Und dann da nur drei Polizisten stehen, das äh sollte dann doch mal aufgeklärt werden,
Daran hat aber natürlich jetzt äh wohl kaum jemand Interesse, viel mehr Interesse haben, alle dieses dann doch sehr.
Wenig Dramatische, wenn man jetzt mal von der ästhetischen Komponente absieht, relativ wenig dramatische Geschehnis dort äh hochzujessen.
Zum Beispiel die CDU. Die CDU würdigt diese paar Spinner direkt mit einer Mitteilung des CDU Präsidiums,
ja, wo sie dann schreiben, die Onlinevernetzung der Feinde unserer Demokratie nimmt weiter zu. Es ist noch nicht hinreichend und schnell genug klar, wer welchen Einfluss auf welche Gruppen ausübt und welche Vernetzung zwischen Rechtsextremen
Q anon und anderen Gruppen besteht. Hier müssen die erforderlichen Mittel für Aufklärung bereitgestellt werden. Ja, dann macht halten Internetausbau
dann könnt ihr im Internet gucken. Das war jetzt nicht besonders schwer herauszufinden, welche Spinner darf zu welchem Quatsch aufrufen, ja? Und wenn du Reichsflaggen vom Parlament hast, dann ist es an der Zeit,
ähm vielleicht auch mal nicht im Internet zu gucken, sondern aus dem Fenster. Also das ist ja wirklich ein Witz. Aber es geht natürlich weiter. Denn wir dürfen nicht vergessen, wir haben's ja mit der CDU zu tun.
Und was sagt die CDU? Natürlich als nächstes? Ja ähm,
Um solche Bedrohungen rechtzeitig erkennen und den technologischen Entwicklungen des einundzwanzigsten Jahrhundert wirksam begegnen zu können,
benötigen unsere Sicherheitsbehörden exzellentes Know-How und beste Technik
klassische Telekommunikationsüberwachung ist angesichts des veränderten Kommunikationsverhaltens und der Nutzung moderner Kommunikationswerkzeuge jedoch nicht geeignet, Tatvorbereitung und Täterstrukturen aufzuklären.
Daher müssen die jeweiligen Sicherheitsbehörden auch über die Instrumente der Onlinedurchsuchung und der Quellen TKÜ sowie forensische Systemkopie von Zielgeräten verfügen. Leute,
Ihr könnt ohne Probleme in diese offenen Telegram-Gruppen reingehen, wo diese Aufrufe verbreitet werden. Da ist nichts weiter für nötig
eine SIM-Karte vom Späti eures Vertrauens, ja? Das ist öffentlich, da brauchst du keine Telekommunikationsüberwachung, da brauchst du kein Staatsrennen, da brauchst du gar nichts. Da musst du einfach nur mal gucken.
Das ist wirklich das ist eine also wie die sich so blöd stellen können, ne, da wirst du ja, da glaubst ja, wirst ja selber irgendwann zum äh zum Verschwörungstheoretiker, ja. Aber nicht, also ne, nicht mit dem Staatstrainer ist natürlich noch nicht.
Äh alles getan. Ach so, abgesehen davon, dass hier gesagt wird, Tatvorbereitung und Täterstrukturen, ne. Bei aller äh ästhetischen Abneigung gegen das, was da passiert ist, ja und
muss ich frage ich mich ernsthaft, ob das überhaupt eine Tat war. Also,
welche Tat ist das denn? Ja, wahrscheinlich irgendwie Landfriedensbruch oder was? Die haben da sogar die Absperrungen noch äh seelenruhig beiseite geräumt, damit die nicht kaputt geht.
Ja die die Treppe da hoch zu gehen, es ist.
Treppe da hoch zu gehen.
Ja, weiß ich auch nicht, was das war.
Ist, ich bin mir nicht sicher, also ich glaube, in letzter Zeit ist da so eine, so ein, so ein,
so ein Security-Check davor, wo du ähm wo du nochmal geröntgt wirst, damit du keine,
damit oder was weiß ich, keine keine Chips mit reinnehmen kannst oder sowas, ne? Aber so grundsätzlich das Betreten der Treppe ist ähm.
Wie sagte Andreas, Geisel, der Innensenator von äh Berlin, so schön, ne. Äh die,
Wir haben das sorgfältig geprüft, aber die freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung gilt leider auch für Arschlöcher und das äh ist, gilt, glaube ich, auch für die Treppe vor dem Reichstag, ja.
Dass man da ähm hoch darf. Ja, insofern bin ich mir noch nicht mal sicher, ob das hier eine Tat.
Ja, also diese Hyperventilation in der in der Politik, die war schon wirklich ein bisschen anstrengend, ne. Also auf einmal, ja.
Ich würde noch, ich würde noch ganz kurz die Hyperventilation zu Ende erzählen, weil mit einem Staatstrianer ist es natürlich nicht getan. Wir brauchen natürlich auch noch, was brauchen wir, Tim?
Richtig, richtig, denn die das CDU-Präsidium teilt uns mit für die Speicherpflicht von Telekommunikationsverkehrsdaten brauchen wir eine rechtssichere Lösung, um schwere Straftaten,
besser verfolgen zu können, sogenannte Vorratsdatensprechung. Manche Straftaten, insbesondere im Bereich der sexuellen Gewalt gegen Kinder lassen sich nur über den Zugriff auf solche Daten aufklären. Im Kampf gegen Terroristen,
sind sie oftmals das entscheidende Mittel um Anschläge zu verhindern. Damit belegen sie genau das, was was ihnen immer äh natürlich,
völlig hypothetisch unterstellt wird, dass solche Forderungen, die solche Formulierungen, die liegen ja fertig in der Schublade. Da wird ja nur oben noch kurz der Anlass geändert.
Ja, also hier Tatvorbereitung, Täterstrukturen, das also tatsächlich, diese Formulierung, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher,
vorher fertig waren, weil nämlich plötzlich nicht mehr die Rede ist von,
von sage ich mal Demokratiefeinden und Monarchisten, sondern einfach nur noch von Tatvorbereitung, Täter, Strukturen, ähm Terrorismus, Kinderpornografie, das ist ein Standardtextblog, den haben die wahrscheinlich auf
Äh hier kennst du diese, wie heißen diese Apps, wo man, weißt du, wo man mehrere Sachen in der Zwischenablage.
Das ist einfach dieselbe Pressemitteilung, die jetzt irgendwie letzten zwanzig Jahre regelmäßig wieder äh repostet wird, ohne dass man dann nennenswerte Änderungen vornimmt. Das ist das ist so das ist so furchtbar, wie berechenbar.
Wobei ich jetzt, ehrlich gesagt, über diese Steigerung, also die Kurzfristigkeit dieser Steigerung schon ein bisschen überrascht bin. Noch schlimmer finde ich ja die Tatsache, dass das überhaupt.
Also ich meine, da müssen dann sozusagen schon jetzt wirklich so Schnuller-Nazis mit äh Reisflaggen.
Kaiser den Kaiser wieder haben wollen, irgendwie unser Parlament stürmen, stürmen, die Treppe hochlaufen.
Die das ist so ein.
Damit die dann so, oh, was, wie, das, die sind irgendwie rechts? Oh, ist uns ja noch gar nicht aufgefallen irgendwie.
Und ich meine, jetzt stell dir einfach mal vor, so in der linken Szene wäre irgendwie so ein Wochenende so vorbereitet worden.
Es doch schon, ich darf daran erinnern, ähm die Aktion, die Toten kommt vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit, die sich zum Ziel gesetzt hatten, ähm,
dann,
hier Gräber auf der Reichstagswiese zu errichten. Auf der Wiese vor dem Reichstag, ja? Und dann war die Wiese abgesperrt und da waren so viele Polizisten äh äh im Einsatz wie wie nie zuvor so ungefähr. Und am Ende haben sie ähm,
war doch noch sogar äh Anke Domscheid äh angezeigt, weil sie mit einer Blume äh äh glaube ich auf auf einen auf einen Polizisten in Schlägermontur mit im im Knüppeleinsatz äh geworfen hatte oder sowas, ne.
Kurz, was Körperverletzung.
Du erinnerst dich.
Ich erinnere mich, ja klar, ich meine, ich erinnere mich an so einiges so, ne? Nur es ist halt ähm.
Das ist so, wenn ich ankündige, ne, wenn ich jetzt twittere, dass ich zum Reichstag gehe, dann stehen da schon fünf Polizisten.
Wegen mir. Aber wenn jetzt so ein irgend so ein wenn irgendwelche äh ähm Reichs Reichsbürger oder was da irgendwie zum Sturm auf das Gebäude äh aufrufen, dann ist das doch äh ist es doch völlig in Ordnung.
Ja, es ist ja noch subtiler. Ich will noch einen anderen äh Fall, den wir hier schon äh öfter mal erwähnt haben, noch hoch holen von äh Andre Holm, ja, die sozusagen,
durch eine Analyse seiner wissenschaftlichen Texte irgendwie.
Die Mitgliedschaft in einer terroristischen Vereinigung vorgeschlagen wurde. Äh unterstellt wurde, die dann jahrelange Überwachung nach sich gezogen hat
Aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie
auf öffentlichen Webseiten und Telegram-Kanälen irgendwie so Revolution, Niedergang des Systems äh wir stürmen den den Bundestag, wie zu den Waffen,
Ja, wenn du das schreibst, also ja, nee, ist jetzt nicht so klar, ob die jetzt, also was die wollen,
Ob das jetzt mal so ernst gemeint ist, gucken wir doch erstmal. Also das, das, das ist wirklich so eine eine Dissonanz, so eine mentale, die ich nicht verstehe.
Ich muss auch noch ganz kurz sagen, also Analyse von Andre Holms arbeiten, ist ein ist ein relativ großes Wort, ne? Das lief ungefähr so, dass damals die äh das war doch die militante Gruppe. Ist ja etwas länger her, vielleicht nur ganz kurz zum Kontext. Andre Holm ist ein ähm,
bekannter und geschätzter äh Soziologe. Der war zu dem Zeitpunkt an der Humboldt Universität zu Berlin am Institut für Sozialwissenschaften äh und hat,
sich mit dem Themenbereich der Gentrification auseinandergesetzt. Generification das Phänomen der Aufwertung ähm von.
Ähm bestimmten äh Stadtbereichen, die also äh zum Beginn dieses Prozesses, sagen wir mal, äh durch günstige Mieten und allgemein einen schlechten Ruf,
attraktiv sind für kreatives Volk, dass dort,
spannende neue, innovative Dinge schafft, sei es ähm alternative Kneipen oder ähm.
Studio Prenzlauer Berg.
Podcast-Studios, ja du hast da Podcast-Studien, Pressauer Bergauer erst aufgemacht, als die Bude saniert, warte.
Ich bin hier die Speerspitze der Gentrifizierung. Ohne mich wäre die Preise ja nie gestiegen.
Genau damit dann zu einem Steigen der Preise äh äh führen und dann dadurch äh zum relativ klar äh dokumentierten und nachweisbaren Verdrängungsprozess derjenige, die sich dort eigentlich niedergelassen haben und dort äh glücklich sind. Und ähm.
Die militante Gruppe hatte sich in ihren Bekennerschreiben unter anderem gegen dieses Phänomen der,
gewendet. So und dann hat die Polizei gedacht, was ist das dann,
kenne ich gar nicht, wir googeln das mal. Und weil André Holm dazu geforscht hat, weil er irgendwie der erste Google-Treffer und dann haben die gesagt, der muss dat sein, der kennt das ist ja der Einzige, der das Wort noch kennt. Also hat der diese Dinger geschrieben. So, die haben danach natürlich dann noch an, dann haben sie irgendwann noch eine Analyse nachgeliefert, aber so ungefähr
funktionieren da die Internetermittlungen. Das heißt, wir haben Belege, wir haben Belege, dass die googeln können.
Und das scheint die in dem Fall nicht gemacht zu haben.
Es ist wirklich hanebüchen. Ja, was soll man dazu nachts groß sagen? Also ähm ein Versagen auf äh,
auf beiden Seiten. Ein sehr feines Versagen auf beiden Seiten,
Da auf beiden Seiten, weil das Versagen bei Attila Hildmann ist ja offensichtlich, das steht ihm ins Gesicht geschrieben, der ist einfach ein ein einziges Versagen,
genau wie die anderen auch, die einfach vollständig darin versagen irgendwie die Realität zu deuten. Aber dann natürlich auch ein vollkommenes Versagen des des des Staates in seiner Reaktion.
Es ist äh es ist wirklich zum Heulen. Und und dann jetzt, also und da bin ich wirklich ähm.
Unglücklich mit der mit der medialen Reaktion, mit der politischen Reaktion, wenn man so ein paar Hanseln für so eine dann doch sehr Aktion gemessen an den Potenzialen, die die hatten, ja? Äh noch so viel Aufmerksamkeit gibt,
dann darfst du dich echt nicht wundern, wenn die sich dadurch bestärkt fühlen, ja? Und ähm ich habe ja gerade schon erwähnt, dass ich in den letzten Tagen mir mal diese einschlägigen Telegram-Kanäle angeschaut habe und.
Ich kann nur sagen, Tim, das ist ein.
Fragtal aus Zugunglücken und Biogasanlagen Explosionen,
und du hast unendlich viele Augen, die du nicht verschließen kannst davor. Da geht dir da das ist,
Das geht auf das spottet jeder Beschreibung, ja? Also besonders spannend sind da die, die Einlassungen von äh genanntem Attila Hildmann, der also wirklich ähm.
Ja, also den, denke ich, da kann man dann doch sagen, dass das
dass da der Verdacht im Raum steht, dass das unter Umständen klinischer Fall sein könnte, ja, wenn ich jetzt mehr sage, dann wird mir ja wieder äh werde ich ja wieder dafür angegriffen, dass ich Leuten Ferndiagnosen erstelle. Aber wenn jemand ähm.
Also.
Nur weil du Psychologie studiert hast, bist du doch noch lange nicht kompetent.
Nein, nein, nein, natürlich nicht, ne? Aber, also das einzig Schöne ist, dass jetzt der Attila Hildmann, der legt sich jetzt mit den Schiefdenkern an, ja? Also er sagt
jeder der sogenannten Aufklärer, die nach dem neunundzwanzigsten achten noch bei
schief denken, noch schief denken verteidigen ist selbst ein Forstfleck, Agent, besser kann man nicht aussortieren wirklich für ein Deutschland einsteht oder nicht, einfach fragen was äh wie sie zu Querdenken steht.
Ähm dem Initiator von Querdenken, diesem Ballweg, unterstellt, Attila Hildmann nun,
Und das ist schon schwere Anschuldigung. Es ginge ihm gar nicht um die Verhinderung der neuen Weltordnung.
Nein
So und dass das wirft er dem vor, ja? Und da sitzen Leute, so was! Der kämpft gar nicht gegen die neue Weltordnung, ja, äh, dann ähm, so schöne Einlass in jeder äh Bewegung gibt es vernünftige und unvernünftige Elemente, so auch bei Q
Ich schätze die Wissensvermittlung vieler Cube-Kanäle sehr. Dennoch warne ich auch vor zu viel Naivität und bedingungslosen Glauben an eine externen.
Kuh kann final eben auch eine sein. Bedingungslos glauben sollte man an seine eigene Kraft und an mich. Ich verdiene an diesem politischen Kampf nichts,
alles auf für die Freiheit und die großartige deutsche Nation. Zwei Posts da drunter kommt dann immer irgendwie Werbung für veganes Matcha-Pulver, als wenn ich jedes Matcha-Pulver vegan, irgendwelche T-Shirts
und sein eigenes Nutella,
Das ist also dieser Telegramkanal. Ich weiß jetzt natürlich auch, dass ich dadurch, dass ich den hier in seiner Absurdität bespreche, wahrscheinlich auch Leute motiviere, da mal reinzugucken. Ähm.
Money äh und das geht in einem durch, ne? Du kannst also das ist erstens zu viel, um es alles zu lesen
Und zweitens kannst du an jeder bedingungslosen Stelle Stopp sagen und du kriegst irgendeinen völlig neuen Irrewitz, ja. Mein Lieblings äh post von gestern war also von denen, die ich gesehen habe, Gleichdreh mit russischem Sender.
Warte mal, stopp,
bevor du bevor du den vorliest, nochmal einen Satz aus dem Letzten, den du gemacht hast, ich warne vor zu viel Naivität und bedingungslosen Glauben an eine externe Macht. So, jetzt bitte nochmal diesen Post.
Vielleicht sollte man auch noch für die Nachwelt erhalten. Wir befinden uns gerade in der Situation, dass sich ähm.
Die das Verhältnis der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, Europa und der USA und eigentlich fast, was weiß ich, so gut wie jeder äh äh freiheitlich demokratischen Nation.
Mit Russland an einem erneuten Tiefpunkt befindet, weil ein äh russischer Regimekritiker mit Namen Nawalni ähm,
ähm einem Giftanschlag äh ausgesetzt wurde und gerade in der Charité Berlin,
ums Überleben kämpft, ja? Und wir sind grade an dem Punkt, dass äh stärkere Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland gefordert werden, sofern äh Russland sich zu diesem Vorfall nicht erklärt, ja? In dieser Zeit,
in dieser Zeit äh schreibt uns Attila Hildmann auf seinem Telegram-Kanal,
mit russischen Sender. Russland fand es gar nicht so toll, wie ich da vor der Botschaft grundlos weggeschleppt wurde.
Russland findet es auch gar nicht gut, wie das BRD-Regime weiter die Gerüchte verbreitet. Putin habe Naval nie vergiftet
und sie finden es auch nicht gut, dass der russische Impfstoff so runtergeredet wird. Ab sofort machen wir Weltpolitik und Deutschland ist wieder vorne mit dabei. Und diesmal auf der guten Seite. Ich danke allen Patrioten
und Unterstützern. Ihr seid meine Helden und werdet es immer bleiben. Ich werde immer für Deutschland einstehen heilig Vaterland.
Auf einmal auf einmal interessiert der sich für Impfstoffe, ne? Also,
vorher warnt er natürlich noch vor der vor dem Impfzwang, dem mit dem wir alle gechipt werden
jetzt ist er natürlich also er ist auch also er hebt natürlich auch ganz klar die nachvollziehbare aber schwer belegbare Anschuldigung Angela Merkel habe den Navalini vergiftet.
Ja und ähm ich ich weiß, also du kannst es natürlich,
freut sich Russland ein Loch im Bauch, wenn vor ihrer eigenen Botschaft in Deutschland ein ein Psychopath
mal eben kurz vor sich selber geschützt wird und dass da ein paar Fotos von gibt, während die,
Welt darüber diskutiert, dass sie mal wieder einen Dissidenten getötet haben, ne. Das ist doch klar, dass die sich da freuen und sagen, Attila, komm, erzähl mal. Haben die dir weh getan? Ne, das ist ja schon relativ klar, ne? Und da.
Alter, es ist ich,
es ist wirklich ein ein Fragalauszug und Glücken, was du da siehst und das ist so.
Also es ist faszinierend und man es ist wirklich auch auf eine Weise wirklich pervers.
Und ja faszinierend, zu was die menschliche Psyche fähig ist, ne? Also.
Man sieht jetzt auch an seiner Postingfrequenz, dass er mit nichts anderem beschäftigt ist und auch relativ wenig zu schlafen scheint, ne. Das Thema beschäftigt ihn ja so. Und ähm das ist also ich.
Also das Schlimmste, was dem Mann passieren kann in in diesem Zustand, ja, ist, dass er diese diese Gefolgschaft hat, die irgendwie, ich glaube, irgendwo zwischen fünfzig und achtzigtausend Menschen sind, die ihm da,
die ganze Zeit wieder Neues reinkippen, ne. Und das ist das ist wirklich, wirklich,
sehr, sehr, sehr tragisch, was da passiert. Und ähm ich weiß da ähm.
Also ich weiß da wirklich nicht mit umzugehen. Vor ein paar Monaten äh hat habe ich so etwas noch für.
Den USA vorbehalten gehalten, ja? Dort allerdings natürlich schon etwas länger manifestiert, aber wenn du dir anhörst, was was die also, wenn das wenigstens in sich kohärent wäre
was diese Leute von sich geben. Wenn man da also irgendwie ein in irgendeiner Form geschlossenes Bild
hätte, ja, was jetzt wo was wenigstens in sich keine Widersprüche mehr hat, ne, aber der schafft es, nicht zwei Posts zu machen, ohne dass sie sich ähm in in in fundamentalen Grundlagen auch widersprechen. Der ist ähm
und das ist natürlich auch klar, dass das ihnen das dann überfordert und auch ja ihm auch Angst macht, ne, also der äh.
Ist wirklich ähm in einem bemitleidenswerten Zustand und ähm die Leute, die ihn da anheizen.
Äh tun ihm auf jeden Fall nicht gut, ob äh ob äh beabsichtigt oder unbeabsichtigt und es scheint ja nun mal so zu sein, dass der tatsächlich da ähm einige,
von den achtzigtausend Leuten äh da, die er da versucht zu erreichen. Wobei, so wie ich das sehe, sind das dann auch immer nur so,
um die fünftausend die online sind, also die tatsächliche Reichweite kann ich da nicht so genau schätzen. Aber da scheinen eben auch Leute drunter zu sein, die das ernst nehmen,
und die stehen dann auf einmal ähm vor der russischen Botschaft und äh bitten um Befreiung. Also hui ui ui ui ui.
Also wir haben's da auf jeden Fall mit einer.
Entfremdung eines äh größeren Teils der Gesellschaft zu tun, der kaum noch einzuholen scheint. Also letzten Endes, ich meine, gut, die sind laut,
und sie müssen auch sehr laut schreien, um überhaupt noch Gehör zu finden. Man kann natürlich jetzt drüber diskutieren
so, ob das sozusagen medial wegschwiegen werden sollte, ja, nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, wie auch immer man das äh nennt oder ob man sich halt auch damit auseinandersetzt. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich, sind so die Umfragen
zu dem Thema auch relativ klar, dass einfach auch wirklich eine nennenswerte, also erhebliche Mehrheit der Deutschen damit einfach überhaupt nicht.
Ausrichten kann. Also ist ja eher so neunzig Prozent Bereich Kopfschütteln. Und das sind dann doch schon deutliche Zahlen.
Was ich tatsächlich auch nicht so ganz verstehe, ist ähm das habe ich hier auch schon mehrmals gesagt, ja? Also ähm die ähm.
Shutdown, Lockdown, wie auch immer man es nennt, Maßnahmen in Deutschland waren schwerwiegend. Äh.
Für bestimmte wirtschaftliche Bereiche. Sie waren,
gleichzeitig bei weitem nicht so äh einschneidend wie in anderen Ländern. Wir sind im im internationalen Vergleich relativ moderat äh durch die, durch die ganze Sache gesegelt. Ähm.
Und,
Ich kenne, wie gesagt, Menschen, denen selber auch äh natürlich von äh wirtschaftlichen Einschnitten relativ stark betroffen durch diese Situation. Ähm.
Und ich kenne Leute, die noch sehr, sehr viel härtere äh finanzielle Situationen grade haben.
Ähm die durchaus, sagen wir mal, Anlass zu Protest haben oder Anlass zur.
Zur Unzufriedenheit oder zum Beispiel auch, ja, in in Anbetracht der jetzigen Situation.
Was das Infektionsgeschehen und die Sterblichkeitsraten angeht, äh natürlich auf eine weitere Lockerung zu pochen, um ihr wirtschaftliches Überleben zu sichern, finde ich völlig, völlig klar. Ähm,
und mit denen kannst du auch äh informierte Gespräche führen, aber ähm wenn ich mir irgendwie angucke.
Die Scheiben, die sind meilenweit davon entfernt, jetzt irgendwie zu meinen, dass das äh Trump oder oder wahlweise Putin einfliegen müssen, um um die Demokratie hier durch eine durch den Kaiserreich zu ersetzen.
Um die Meinungsfreiheit wieder herzustellen. Also das ist das ist dann wirklich bizarre und ähm musste tatsächlich an diesen Begriff denken. Das ist ein Begriff, den ich aus dem äh Psychologiestudium kenne, also bizarrer waren.
Ein Diagnosekriterium äh und da würde ich sagen, das da sind viele dieser Menschen, wenn man die mal reden hört und versucht,
eine Kohärenz in überhaupt in dem zu finden, was sie sagen. Kann ja sein, dass das äh Virus
ähm eine äh Lüge ist, ja, dann müsste aber eben auch alles, was die sagen, sich damit decken. Dann kann ich auf einmal der russische Impfstoff gut sein, ja. Und äh kann auch sein, dass sie ihre Meinungsfreiheit,
nicht ausreichend gewürdigt sehen, wenn sie mit Reichsflaggen vor dem Parlamentsgebäude demonstrieren dürfen
Kann sein, vielleicht ist das ist damit Ihrer freien Entfaltung noch nicht genüge getan und Sie fühlen sich immer noch eingeschränkt, dann verstehe ich aber nicht, warum die ausgerechneten Kaiserreich zurück haben wollen, ja? Also das ist.
Das ist wirklich beängstigend. Und ich habe ähm.
Habe den Eindruck, dass wir äh in zunehmendem Maße uns damit auseinandersetzen müssen, dass das Internet hier eine entscheidende Rolle spielt. Ja und ein paar Substanzen, von denen wir noch nicht genau wissen, welche das sind.
Genau.
Auch übrigens nur, wir haben jetzt hier sehr viel über äh Attila Hildmann gesprochen. Es gibt dann ähm natürlich auch noch eine ganze Reihe.
Leute, die vielleicht noch, also denen man nicht direkt.
Auf den ersten Blick ansieht, dass sie oder sagen wir mal, für die, die Entschuldigung des.
Anfangsverdachts einer vielleicht mäßigen, temporären, psychischen Beeinträchtigung nicht gilt. Ja, ähm.
Und was äh wie die sich so über diese Sachverhalte äußern, da wird's halt auch schon schon schnell unterhaltsam. Wenn du die also.
Gehen wir mal ich ich verstehe irgendwie gar nicht, was jetzt der Schaden durch so eine Maske ist. Wenn in einem Jahr sich rausstellen sollte, dass mit der Maske war alles Unsinn, hättest du genauso gut sein lassen können, ne? Dann werde ich, dann würde ich sagen, ja, okay.
War war Unsinn, habe ich äh in dem ganzen Jahr vierzig Euro für Masken ausgegeben,
hätte ich hätte ich gar nicht machen müssen. So das also ich verstehe nicht, wo die Beeinträchtigung ist, die diese Menschen in ihrem Leben noch fühlen.
Also, na ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ja nicht um die Maske, es die Maske ist nur das Symbol.
Richtig und äh jetzt möchte ich, weil wir jetzt so viel äh über Attila Hildmanns Einlassung gesprochen haben, wollte ich nur darauf hinweisen, dass es eben andere gibt, die sage ich mal, weniger aufgeregt
wirken aber den gleichen Quatsch reden und insbesondere diese schief denken Leute sind ja jetzt an dem Punkt dass sie sich,
Ähm also erstens, weil da hielt man sie angreift und äh sie gleichzeitig,
nicht an diesem Reichstagssturm beteiligt waren, sich jetzt so ein bisschen als die moderate.
Alternative darstellen können, ja? Und da würde ich dann gerne diesen Ballweg nochmal zitieren in einem Interview mit dem Südwestrundfunk. Ähm,
Was ich gesehen habe sind Reichsflagen. Da haben wir die Ordner, die Eskalationsteams auch hingeschickt und haben die Menschen dazu mal befragt, wo sie,
ob sie denn wissen, was das für eine Flagge ist. Von vielen Teilnehmern haben wir gehört, dass diese Flaggen verteilt wurden und dass sie gar nicht wissen, wofür diese Flagge steht.
Da würde ich jetzt mal ganz kurz einwerfen. Wenn deine Demonstration voller Leute ist, die Flaggen hochhalten, von denen sie nicht wissen, was die bedeuten, ne? Dann zählen die nur halb,
Das sind nämlich absolut hierhin amputierte Idioten, denen kannst du ja alles in die Hand drücken. Wenn dir eine schwarz-weiß-rote Fahne hochhalten, erstens ohne zu wissen, was das ist und zweitens überhaupt irgendeine Fahne hochhalten, ohne zu wissen, was das ist. Halte ich also für eine ähm.
Entweder schwer haltbare ähm Aussage oder ein äh sehr treffliches Urteil über den Geisteszustand der der Demonstrierenden. Aber er sagt noch weiter.
In der Bundespressekonferenz wurde ja bestätigt, dass auch V-Leute unterwegs waren. Von daher kann ich nur sagen
Es wäre ein Untersuchungsausschuss hilfreich, der mal den Einsatz von V-Leuten klärt und hier auch direkt die Aufforderung an die CDU in Berlin für lückenlose Aufklärung zu sorgen, wo die denn herkommen,
Deeskalationsteam haben haben mit den Teilnehmern geredet, die die Flaggen hatten, die haben dann
die dann auch runtergenommen, weil sie eben nicht wussten, wofür die standen. Das heißt, er legt hier nahe, dass die Regierung,
seinen Querdenkern da, ja, die er so kritisch denken,
Ne, die alles hier in Frage stellen, die immer den Mut haben, sich ihres eigenen Verstandes zu bedienen, gemein und hinterhältig, Reichsflaggen untergejubelt hat, die wussten aber gar nicht, was das ist
Aber weil die so so gut quer gedacht haben, ne, weil die so gut alles in Frage gestellt haben, haben die die mal hochgehalten? Alter, wirklich, ey.
Manchmal ist es doch sinnvoller, geradeaus zu denken und nicht.
Geradeaus denken ist manchmal gar nicht so blöd ne na ja.
Lass uns das Kapitel schließen. Ich denke.
Kommen wir zu den richtigen Verschwörungen.
Erstmal alles zugesagt. Genau. Nicht den Anfängerkram.
Ähm es gab einen, ein Gerichtsurteil in den USA und zwar am Nein,
Circuit Court of Appe Peals, also ein Berufungsgericht.
Vor dem ein äh five verhandelt wurde von Menschen, äh die zwanzig dreizehn verurteilt wurden, weil sie,
offenbar Geld an eine Terroristengruppe äh mit dem Namen Al-Shabaab äh gespendet hatten. Und ähm diese.
Gegen dieses Urteil sind die in Berufung gegangen aufgrund der Datenerfassung, die diesem Urteil zu Grunde liegt und ähm.
Haben Sie spezifisch gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gewidmet, äh gewendet, die AdWord Snowden als Beginn,
seiner Veröffentlichung sehr zu Beginn seiner Veröffentlichung beziehungsweise die aus den Informationen von stammen und die relativ zu Beginn
der äh Snowden Veröffentlichung von Jane Green World und Laurer Poetrys öffentlich gemacht wurde. Also Meterdatensammlung und Vorratsdatenspeicherung in den USA
und diese illegale Erfassung.
Oder der der Verdacht, dass diese Erfassung verfassungswidrig ist, hat hier, weil hier der Anlass für dieses äh Berufungsverfahren und das Gericht hat geurteilt, dass eben diese ähm Massenüberwachung.
Die ähm zwanzig fünfzehn nach den Snowden Enthüllungen beendet wurde, eben ähm das äh den vierten Zusatzartikelment und
die Verfassung verletzt hat, also verfassungswidrig war, hat allerdings nicht über die Metadatenerfassung geurteilt, weil die Metadatenerfassung für diese Verurteilung in diesem Berufungsverfahren unerheblich war.
Ähm das heißt, es ist jetzt hier so meines Erachtens, dass erste.
Gerichtsurteil, das direkt auf dieses Snowden-Veröffentlichung in Bezug nimmt, etwas, was also die Öffentlichkeit vorher nicht wusste und,
bestätigt, dass es verfassungswidrig war, was äh natürlich besondere Konsequenzen für den Status adwit Snows als Whistleblower hat
Ja, wenn du eben eine äh eine Information an die Öffentlichkeit trägst, mit der mit dem Argument
die ist äh der Öffentlichkeit würdig, das muss die Öffentlichkeit wissen, ist das etwas anderes, als wenn diese Information sich eben auch als verfassungswidriges Gebaren herausstellt. Ähm,
es wird aber noch bemängelt, dass das äh ich glaube, das heißt, äh Fruit of the poisones tree, also dass wenn eine Datenerfassung illegal war.
Dieses Beweismittel auch vor Gericht nicht mehr verwendbar ist. Dieses äh diese Argumentation hat das äh Berufungsgericht hier nicht gelten lassen. Das heißt, die äh Verurteilung,
bleibt in der Form den äh Beschuldigten erhalten. Aber es scheint mir die erste,
Anerkennung zu sein, dass hier eben das, was Edward Snowden aufgeklärt hat, ein,
widriges Verhalten der USA gegen die eigenen Bürger war. Und da sind die USA ja immer sehr empfindlich, weil ähm mit mit dem Rest der Weltkatze mach, was du willst, das ist ja nur gut und billig, aber wenn du äh gegen Amerikaner spionierst, da hat äh,
geht so nicht.
Also wo ich mir nicht so hundertprozentig sicher bin, ist jetzt, wie viel Bestand dieses Urteil hat, weil äh dieses Berufungsgericht, also nein Circuit, Corto für Peals heißt
quasi das ist so ein buntes Gericht, ein Bundesberufungsgericht
ähm neins Circle, also es gibt da irgendwie dreizehn in den USA und der neunte ist jetzt quasi zuständig so für den ganzen Westen, also so Washington,
Kalifornien und Nevada und solche Staaten und wenn ich das richtig sehe,
stehen die dann natürlich dann noch dem Supreme Court, sprich könnte auch sein, das weiß ich aber jetzt nicht, dass das dann letzten Endes auf der Ebene,
entschieden wird und da wissen wir ja wie da gerade die Verteilung aussieht, nicht so gut.
Ich habe auch, ich kenne die Gerichtestruktur in den USA nicht so genau. Du hast das gerade schon geschildert, was wir wissen. Immerhin ist diese,
Richterin, die da geurteilt hat, aber auch eine direkte äh pointie von Clinton.
Anderen Worten, das ist schon ein relativ hohes Gericht, aber eben nicht das Entscheidende Gericht, welches über Verfassungsgemäßheit von Maßnahmen urteilt, was natürlich das äh der Supreme Court wäre.
So, dann hatten wir in der letzten Woche ja über diese digitale äh Corona-Liste gesprochen
das zerrt sich angeschaut hat Sophie. Vom CRT hat uns ja darauf davon berichtet. Und ähm bei solchen Veröffentlichungen ist natürlich immer ganz interessant,
wie verhält sich denn die Konkurrenz? Ja, wenn die Konkurrenz klug ist, äh hält sie einfach den Mund,
und äußert sich nicht dazu
wenn sie äh Lust hat auch mal Besuch vom CCC zu bekommen, dann könnte sie zum Beispiel etwas twittern von einem nicht auf alle schließen, digital und sicher funktioniert unsere Lösung. Gut, dass sich nun die Spreu vom Weizen trennt.
Wir gehen auf saubere IT-Architektur und Private Public Key Verschlüsselung. Ähm.
Ist uns dann äh natürlich aufgefallen und ähm Martin hat dann gesagt, ach ja, Mensch, dann schauen wir uns doch mal dieses System an.
System funktioniert so, du hast 'ne also gehst auf 'ne Webseite und diese Webseite gehört einer,
Einrichtung, das kann eine gastronomische Einrichtung sein, die aber nicht nur Gastronomen als Kunden. Und wenn du dort jetzt Daten hinterlässt, dann werden die,
verschlüsselt an diese Einrichtung.
Also wenn du dich dort anmeldest als als Einrichtung, dann würfelst du im Browser Public Privatepair.
Kann man sich so vorstellen wie bei PGP, ne? Du hast den öffentlichen Schlüssel, den privaten Schlüssel an den öffentlichen Schlüssel verschlüsselte Informationen können nur mit dem privaten Schlüssel entschlüsselt werden und der private Schlüssel ist eben bei der Anbieterin
Ja? Ähm schöne Idee für für diese Lösung. Und äh das hat eben zur Folge, dass die Betreiber,
dieser Plattform nur verschlüsselte Daten speichern, die sie auch selber nicht entschlüsseln können, sondern nur die,
Gastronomen oder Einrichtungen im Fall der Fälle, dass sie eben diese Daten abrufen. Eigentlich eine sehr schöne Idee,
Ähm jetzt hat Martin sich da angemeldet und hat festgestellt, dass er genau dicker, also es ist die gleiche Kategorie Fehler, wie bei der anderen Plattform. Du kannst als Beschreiber A,
den Schlüssel von Beschreiber B überschreiben. Ähm was dann zur Folge hat, dass zukünftig alle Eintragungen bei Betreiber B.
Deinem Schlüssel verschlüsselt sind. Die Konsequenz davon ist, der Betreiber B kommt nicht mehr an die Daten, dafür aber du.
Ja, könnte also genau, erstens, andere lesen, äh können das lesen und andererseits, wenn dann wirklich mal die Daten erfragt werden vom Gesundheitsamt, können sie nicht.
Kannst du es nicht mehr, ja. Ähm dummerweise ist die, war die Sache auch noch so gebaut, dass jetzt quasi der der Key nicht.
Also dass das kleinsseitig nicht aufgefallen ist, ist jetzt auch nicht so einfach, aber die einfachste Möglichkeit wäre gewesen die Arbeit mit zu QR-Codes, ne? Und eine,
nicht perfekte aber eine gute Lösung wäre gewesen, dass der Fingerprint des Schlüssels,
direkt noch mit in dem QR-Code ist, so dass wenn du den QR-Codes gönnst und da ein anderer Schlüssel dir angeboten wird, deine App sagt oder dein dein Browser sagt, nee, Moment mal, den den Schlüssel, das ist nicht der, den ich hier haben wollte.
Ne? Ähm hat, wenn du das nur im Webmaß noch eine Lücke, aber äh dadurch, dass diese Maßnahme nicht,
implementiert war, ging dieser Schlüsselaustausch. Ja, sonst hätte man diesen Angriff nicht realistisch durchführen können. Außerdem haben sie noch ein ähm,
für ihre also für ihre für ihre Onlinepräsenz ein Content Managementsystem gehabt
wo Martin dann Admin Zugriff und Remote Code Execution hatte. Damit konnte er aber, also konnte er diese Seite verändern und beliebigen Code auf dem Server ausführen, aber nicht Einfluss nehmen auf diese,
contact tracing Funktion. Ähm.
Ja, was haben wir gemacht? Bericht geschrieben ähm und haben den diesen Bericht, ich glaube, das war,
Ja, äh Dienstag Abend um siebzehn Uhr habe ich den dahin gemailt ähm und am
Mittwoch um zwölf hatte ich dann eine Antwort. Alles klar, ist alles behoben. Vielen Dank. Sind da noch ein bisschen im Austausch gewesen, haben wir nochmal telefoniert darüber. Ähm dabei ist mir dann noch eine weitere kleine Schwachstelle aufgefallen, die ich,
mitgeteilt habe, ähm die ich jetzt über die wir jetzt noch nicht öffentlich berichtet haben, weil die sich noch in der Behebung befinden sollte im Moment.
Aber war ähm
eine ganz schöne ähm war ein ganz netter Austausch. Das ist ein Team, die haben äh dieses System im Rahmen des Via versus Virus Hackefones gebastelt, haben dann irgendwie Unterstützung vom irgendwie bayrischen Ministerium für,
Digitales oder sowas äh und vom DEHOGA deutschen Hotel und Gaststättenverband äh bekommen, um das Ding jetzt irgendwie mal groß zu ziehen. Haben da drin so äh um die tausend,
ähm Einrichtungen schon angebunden, hatten ich glaube insgesamt siebentausend Erfassungen, aber jetzt kommt's,
Äh betroffen waren nur viertausend, weil die der Löschfrist nachkommen. Wuppdidu, die löschen die Daten, anders als äh der Anbieter Gastronomie, über den wir letzte Woche äh gesprochen haben. Und man muss eben auch ganz klar sagen.
Die Verschlüsselung hier war äh nur ähm in die Zukunft ähm kaputt machbar
Ja, aber Retrokrat konntest du nicht auf die Daten zugreifen. Das heißt, diese zu dem Zeitpunkt des Zugriffs vierhunderttausend dadrin gespeicherten Daten, waren geschützt und zwar aufgrund der Verschlüsselung. Ich habe dann in der
CCC-Pressemitteilung als als Fazit geschrieben,
Es es zeigt sich, siehst du das einfach ganz kurz vor, ja? Nicht selten wird Verschlüsselung von Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Geheimdiensten verteufelt. Am vorliegenden Beispiel zeigt sich einerseits ihre Wichtigkeit für Datenschutz, Privatsphäre und IT-Sicherheit.
Dank Verschlüsselung blieben über vierhunderttausend Datensätze und über eintausend Einrichtungen vor fremden Zugriff geschützt.
Dreihunderttausend Datensätze blieben geschützt, weil die Betreiber der Löschpflicht nachkommen. Andererseits zeigen sich auch übliche Tücken bei der Implementierung. Wenn die Schlüsse nicht unabhängig verifiziert werden, können sie unbemerkt ausgetauscht werden,
und wenn Daten mit dem falschen Schlüssel verschlüsselt sind, sind sie verloren. Aber, ja, hier, also es gab,
durchaus kritische Schwachstellen, aber einfach nur aufgrund dieser Verschlüsselung ist hier eben von,
von einem ist hier eben der Go äh vermieden gewesen, ne. Das heißt ähm hat einen Schwachstellenverschlüsselung, hat aber dafür gesorgt, dass die ähm.
Im Prinzip.
Der Schaden begrenzt war, sagen wir es mal so, ne.
Schaden ist begrenzt auf das, auf das Ego der äh der Entwickler. Aber die sind da auch äh sportlich gewesen.
Plattform heißt, äh darf ich rein DE, muss man ja schon noch dazu sagen.
Bin ich mal gespannt, wie das so weiterläuft mit den digitalen Coronalisten.
Ja
Wir brauchen ja irgendwie mal ein neues, ein neues Dauerthema diese Corona-Warn-App. Interessiert mich langsam nicht mehr. Ähm,
Nee, ich bin auch beleidigt. Äh Corona-Warn-App hat mich beleidigt, ja, weil ähm ich habe neun neuen Begegnungen in der App.
So. Finde ich äh ist zu viel. Also es reicht
Mario hatte da mal so, also Mario, es hat äh gefordert, Mario Sixus wollte sehen, hat auf Twitter gesagt, wer wer weniger als zwei äh Risikobegegnungen hatte, ist Sozialtot,
Insofern ist das natürlich auch eine gute Nachricht. Äh ich hatte den Eindruck, äh kann sein, dass sich da noch was geändert hat, aber mehr als neun, konnte da bisher niemand vorweisen. Äh ich.
Versuche mir das schön zu reden, dass das eventuell die die Schlange beim Testzentrum war.
Käme so, käme so ungefähr hin, käme käme so ungefähr hin, aber aber wenn ich ganz ehrlich sein soll, äh da war keine Schlange zu der Zeit, wo ich da waren, sofern.
Da, da sollte man vielleicht Bluetooth ausschalten.
Ey, komm.
Nee, ich habe kein, ich habe keine Ahnung, äh woher diese äh Begegnung kommen, das waren ähm.
Mit einem Mal äh mit einem Update kamen da fünf dazu. Ähm jetzt muss man natürlich sagen, ich wohne im relativ belebten Teil von Berlin und gehe äh wie ich ja schon damals gesagt habe, regelmäßig spazieren. Ich kann also.
Diese Begegnungen passieren mir dann, aber Neuen ist natürlich trotzdem eine etwas unschöne Zahl, also man will ja einfach so was wie dreiundzwanzig oder zweiundvierzig, ne, mindestens eine Primzahl müsste, müsste da jetzt schon noch kommen.
Ja, aber ich meine, das bedeutet ja im Umkehrschluss auch, dass innerhalb von vierzehn Tagen du neun.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz überlegen, wie man das übersetzen kann. Also in.
Kann man das in Personen umrechnen, ja, kann man.
Du kannst das nicht unbedingt die Kies sind ja.
Also Tag.
Pro Person und Tag. Das heißt, es könnte sein, dass es eine Person ist, die ich an neun.
Genau.
Das ist aber nicht so, weil ich hatte einmal zwei, dann vier dann neun. Das heißt, äh,
Es sind mindestens drei Personen, mit denen ich mindestens einmal mindestens an zwei, einmal mindestens an drei und einmal mindestens an fünf Tagen Kontakt hatte. Ähm,
Also ist das der niedrigste Wert bei meinem Profil wären nee, Quatsch.
Bekommst du da jetzt drauf? Das kann ich.
Doch, ja genau, doch. Na, weil mit einem also mit also wenn ein Update kommt.
Ja? Also du, du kriegst eine du, es kommt eine Risikobegegnung. So, die, also das, die App macht ihr Update. Es kann immer nur äh es gibt pro Person ein Kie pro Tag, aus dem die ganzen anderen abgeleitet werden, ja?
Ähm das bedeutet.
Wenn ich zwei habe, dann habe ich entweder zwei Personen an einem Tag, zwei Personen an unterschiedlichen Tagen oder eine Person an zwei Tagen.
Ja? Das heißt, jedes Update von Begegnungen können,
muss immer mindestens eine Person sein, potenziell an unterschiedlichen Tagen. Da ich in drei Updates hochgegangen bin, also auf zwei auf vier auf neun, müssen es mindestens drei Personen sein.
Mhm. Okay.
Es könnten.
Bis zu neun Personen sein unter der Annahme, dass sich jeder Person nur an einem Tag begegnet bin. Wäre es aber so, dass ich einer Person an mehreren Tagen begegnet bin, würde das trotzdem.
Aufgrund der unterschiedlichen Tage ähm zählen als.
Einzelne Begegnungen. Also der Wert der Person mit die ein positives Testergebnis über die Corona-Warnapp eingecheckt haben und sich kurzfristig auf größere Distanz in meiner Nähe befunden haben, ist zwischen liegt zwischen drei und neun.
Also, das finde ich trotzdem eine relativ bemerkenswert hohe Zahl. Ja, ich meine, du äh wohnst in so einem Stadtteil.
Ist egal wo ich wohne.
Ich weiß, aber,
so ein so ein Berliner Stadtteil, der halt schon irgendwie mehr als zehntausend Einwohner hat und wenn du innerhalb von vierzehn Tagen drei Leuten, an drei Leuten vorbeigehst,
die sich dann in diesem Zeitraum positiv melden mit der Corona-Warn-App. Das ist schon eine Menge.
Und das müsstest du jetzt theoretisch mal äh sechs nehmen.
Weil du ja nur äh fünfzehn, vierzehn Millionen Aktive dieser Apps hast.
Mit anderen Worten ähm müsstest du davon ausgehen, wenn die infizierten,
unter den Corona-Warnip Nutzerinnen und den Nicht-Corona-Warn-App-Nutzerinnen gleich verteilt sind, wäre der zu erwartende Wert diese Anzahl an Personen mal ungefähr sechs.
Oder fünf, je nachdem, wo du jetzt eine Altersgrenze ziehst, wo du sagst, so, ja, aber der Platz ist schon.
Der funktioniert nicht. Det kann schon, das kann schon noch werden.
Na ja, also es gleichzeitig sind die alle natürlich, also sind alle unter dieser Schwelle, dass ich mir äh Sorgen machen sollen müsste.
Ja Bruder, du bist ja auch getestet worden, bist negativ. Also von daher passt das ja.
Ey, hallo, ich habe nicht gesagt, wie mein Test war. Jetzt plapperst du hier meine meine Medizindaten aus oder was?
Ach so, dann nehme ich das raus.
Bist du ja auch positiv.
Das wollte ich dir jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass du negativ.
Was meinst du warum, was meinst du warum ich endlich mal wieder in der Metaebene mit dir podcasten wollte?
Ja, hier guckst du nur mit Tess rein. Musst mir vorher einen passenden Screenshot zeigen. So, bei.
Jo dann noch kleine Kurzmeldung und zwar.
Facebook hat jetzt angekündigt, dass sie politische Anzeigen vor der US-Wahl irgendwie stoppen wollen. Äh sieben Tage vor der Wahl nehmen sie keine politischen Anzeigen mehr an. Fragst du dich auch, was das soll. Die Kampagnen sind ja gerade in, in, in, im, in voller Fahrt, ja?
Dass da also da das erscheint mir etwas halbherzig und es scheint mir auch ein bisschen das Problem zu verkennen.
Weil was wir ja im Moment sehen mit den Desinformationskampagnen, dass die eben äh nicht nicht mehr
unbedingt über über Facebookanzeigen funktionieren, ähm aber immerhin,
erkennt Facebook jetzt mal so dieses dieses Problem an und äh hat da jetzt eine Task Force um sich mit diesem Thema auseinanderzusetzen. Das ist ja schon mal ein bisschen ein bisschen andere Situation als sie äh noch vor vier Jahren war.
Man merkt zumindest, dass hier etwas unter Druck stehen. Sie tun nicht genug, aber äh ihre, ihre, ihre Situation ist zumindest schon mal latent erschüttert.
Ja. Dann haben wir ähm.
Uns in der vorletzten Sendung, glaube ich, auch damit auseinandergesetzt, dass es da ja jetzt ein Streit ist, Supermächte, um die sozialen Netzwerke gibt. Ähm ich hatte das ja ungefähr so beurteilt, dass äh diese.
Unternehmen, um die es da geht, sowieso keine Sympathieträger sind. Ähm und ähm.
Es aber natürlich sich jetzt auch hier offenbart, ja, wenn wenn die USA mit Facebook Intelligence über die gesamte Welt sammeln, das sind das natürlich nicht gefällt, wenn die Chinesen auf einmal auch ein soziales Netzwerk haben, in dem Fall TikTok und ähm
was da jetzt ja passiert ist, dass eine Art,
Erpressung von den USA stattfindet, die im Prinzip durch das Executive Order von Trump mehr oder weniger TikTok den Geschäfts
betrieb in den USA so erschweren will, dass die nicht weiter äh in diesem Land operieren können.
Äh während äh US-amerikanische Unternehmen eben denen diesen Geschäftsbereich kaufen sollen, interessierte Käufer sind äh Microsoft und Warmart äh auf der einen Seite und ORR auf der anderen.
Ähm und jetzt hat offenbar äh also das Manöver von Trump war ja hier äh relativ klar.
Preis drücken, erpressen und dann eben den, diesen Geschäftsbetrieb quasi zum günstigen Preis äh wegschnappen
fast schon echt ziemlich perfide ist. China wehrt sich jetzt dagegen und zwar haben die gesagt, äh also das ist das Wirtschaftsministerium, hat die Liste an Technologien, für die man Exportgenehmigung braucht,
wenn man sie ins Ausland verkauft, aktualisiert und hat jetzt Datenanalyse und künstliche Intelligenz.
Mit auf diese Liste genommen. Und äh das soll ja der kluge Kern von TikTok sein, äh mit mit anderen Worten, sie hat sie haben jetzt vom Wirtschaftsministerium eine.
Grundsätzliche Verkaufsrestriktion. Auf TikTok, was ist potentiell ermöglichen kann, dass China,
einen Verkauf an die USA verhindert? Ähm.
Meine Interpretation der ganzen Sache ist, dass China sich im Prinzip sagt, okay bevor wir uns hier von den USA erpressen lassen, dann soll halt eben,
dieser TikTok Betreiber platt gehen, ja? Das ist immer noch besser, als wenn wir uns unsere Werkzeuge hier weg erpressen lassen. Bin mal äh interessiert,
wie das weitergeht. Schön ist das nicht, diese gesamte Auseinandersetzung äh und schön ist auch das Phänomen nicht, dass es überhaupt diese äh Netzwerke gibt, aber äh mehr dazu könnt ihr dann in meinem äh Telegram-Kanal lesen.
Richtig.
Merkel du Sauersinn, Navalini vergiftet. Meine ist schauderhaft.
Ich gehe lieber auf TikTok. Ich mache, ich gehe auch auf TikTok, ich mache so so Podcast-Dance.
Tänze, schön tanze.
Man muss ja jetzt immer so mit den Armen wackeln, ne? Weil man darf ja nicht mehr so ausladen tanzen.
Na weil's alles vertikal Video ist, da passt eine ausladende Bewegung äh nicht drauf, ne? Deswegen entwickeln sich halt auf Tickets so Tanzstile, die alle so auf vertikal getrennt sind. Und das ist halt da.
Mich schon gewundert, warum die Leute los ist.
Ja. Sind alles so Erkenntnisse, ne? Technologie formt die Gesellschaft. Das kann man nicht anders sagen.
Den Volkslehrer haben wir übrigens vergessen zu erwähnen. Den habe ich hier auch noch.
Das ist doch gut.
Das ist so ein so ein auch so ein.
Den ich erwähnt habe, das ist gut. Nicht, dass das dann noch Leute hören und dann da drauf klicken. Ich denke, wir sind jetzt am Ende äh dieses Beitrags hier angekommen.
Und äh ja, wie immer wollen wir.
Ich lese gerade hier nur wieder die neuesten News von Attila. Äh fünf G Strahler, also die US-Behörde NI Age bestätigt fünf G Strahlung kann Corona-Erkrankungen verursachen.
Äh
Telegramm Strahlung kann auf jeden Fall ordentliche äh Nerven, mentale.
Also Telegram Strahlung, da wäre ich echt vorsichtig, da da strahlt ihr direkt bis hinten.
Da hat er leider eine Überdosis bekommen.
Attila Hildmann.
Dinos. Wir machen jetzt hier den Kanal.
Deutschland muss und wird wieder erstarken in all seiner Kraft und Herrlichkeit. Samurai Shirts und Hoodies, Biofair von Attila Hildmann. Brauchst den Samurai-Shirt, damit Deutschland äh erstarkt.
Ich brauche gleich ein Samuraischwert, um irgendwie diese Sendung noch weiter ertragen zu können.
Du lebst, du lebst in keinem souveränen Staat, sondern in einer Besatzerzone, die.
Du bist kein Mensch mit.
Nahe. Diese BRD-Firma haben.
Auf, das Deutsche Reich gesetzt.
Wir brauchen ein, wir brauchen einen Friedensvertrag mit Deutschland. Nee, damit Deutschland wieder souverän bin.
Und verlinkt hat er dieses Handelsregister die Finanzagentur GmbH der Bundesrepublik Deutschland?
Tja, schlechte Nachrichten, Deutschland hat kapituliert, da ist kein Friesenvertrag mehr drin.
Nein, die Wehrmacht hat kapituliert. Es war nur die Wehrmacht. Tim.
Na ja okay, reicht ja. Ich ich bin übrigens auch kurz davor zum Kapitulieren, wenn du dieses Thema dich langsam von der Agenda nimmst. Oh Mann.
Davon abraten, ich kann echt nur davon abraten, das ist wie so eine wirklich.
Verkehrsunfall, wo man nicht weggucken kann. Stimmt's? Ja, ja, sag das doch.
Tal auf Verkehrsunfallen. Ey, das ist unglaublich, ey. Na ja, okay.
Okay.
Und zum Schluss wollen wir heute nochmal einen ganz besonderen Dank loswerden und dieser Dank geht an Sebski.
Und damit lassen wir euch jetzt erstmal wieder alleine mit der Woche. Ich hoffe, es kommt nicht so hart. Also Kopf hoch und bis später.
Kauft Attila Hiltmanns T-Shirts und Macher Tee und Nuss.